[Music]  what has happened to colossal military  disaster she'll go on to the end we  shall never surrender the call went out  we have to go to Dunkirk ready on the  stern line we do it sure where we're  going into war Gorge of the useful sir  what about economy  I'm on else  about Philippe  and don't need to send more [ __ ] every  time you close up  - that created the cylinders  digit when you destroy it  oh don't son Kirk  night for your little Zach your weekend  sale another bloody Navy should be at  home  he's no hiding from this Sun we have a  job to do  if you fight on beaches provide from the  landing ground  we never surrender  the USA in this  wait a bloody airport  you  you